[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public 90 minutes de débats
de reportage et d'analyse comme tous les
soirs sur Public Sénat 18h et 22h avec
nos experts on donne du sens à
l'actualité on vous propose des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société avec un débat d'actu pour
commencer Vladimir Poutine qui déclare
la loi martiale dans les régions du
crinienne récemment annexé la population
de Carson est évacuée avant la bataille
pour cette ville proche de la Crimée
quelle est la stratégie du président
russe est-il en train de vider l'Ukraine
d'une partie de ses habitants la réponse
de nos invités dans une minute et puis
dans la seconde partie de l'émission
C'est un débat volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour que je vous propose
on prend du recul pour comprendre la
crise qui secoue le cinéma français les
causes sont multiples le prix des places
évidemment et puis la concurrence des
plateformes l'ensemble du métier est en
train de basculer sur les plateformes et
que le cinéma la salle doit absolument
rester concurrentiel en présentant des
films qui vaillent la peine de sortir de
chez soi le cinéma français est-il en
danger produit-on trop de films et pas
assez pour le grand public ne ratez pas
notre débat dans trois quarts d'heure
mais d'abord les dernières décisions
européennes pour soutenir l'Ukraine des
sanctions qui visent les fournisseurs de
drone iraniens à la Russie Sandra
serkira
se cacher en attendant la fin des
bombardements parfois pendant plusieurs
heures dans ce passage souterrain de
Kiev la scène est devenue quotidienne
presque banale face à la reprise des
raids aériens menées par les forces
russes si je ne suis pas chez moi je me
mets à l'abri dans le métro ou un
passage souterrain comme ici toute ma
famille suis ses règles nous pouvons
rester ainsi en sécurité et tout le
monde est en vie nous résistons et je
pense que nous allons gagner
en perte de vitesse sur le terrain
militaire l'état-major russe cible des
infrastructures stratégiques à
l'approche de l'hiver avec des drones
d'origine iranienne conséquences des
destructions qui s'appelle sa population
à réduire sa consommation d'énergie les
drones Iraniens sont des armes légères
peu coûteuses et programmées pour
atteindre un objectif défini à l'avance
selon le président zellinsky l'armée
ukrainienne parvient régulièrement en
intercepter nous avons des résultats
significatifs avec 133 drones iraniens
abattus des dizaines de missiles ont été
abattus depuis un
une affirmation qui m'était errant sous
pression à la sortie d'une réunion
extraordinaire du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU l'ambassadeur de la République
islamique dément ses accusations
l'Iran rejette catégoriquement les
allégations infondées selon lesquelles
l'Iran aurait transféré des drones pour
les utiliser dans le cadre du conflit en
Ukraine
la rupture des relations diplomatiques
avec l'Iran est à l'étude l'Union
européenne qui dit avoir des preuves de
l'utilisation d'armes iraniennes en
Ukraine a décidé d'une série de
sanctions contre une compagnie aérienne
et trois responsables militaires
iraniens ayant fourni des drones à la
Russie
j'accueille tout de suite Gallia Kerman
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver sur ce
plateau vous êtes historienne
spécialiste de la Russie directrice de
la rédaction du média en ligne d'escrucy
et vous avez dirigé le numéro
77 de la revue La Règle du jeu on va le
voir à l'image c'est une somme un numéro
spéciale de plus de 500 pages consacré à
l'Ukraine et à la Russie Irina mitrychin
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
maître de conférence à l'Institut
national des langues et civilisations
orientale responsable des études
ukrainiennes j'accueule le général
Christophe gomard bonsoir bienvenue à
vous ancien chef du renseignement
militaire Laetitia cruppa éditoris
politique bonsoir Laetitia et bienvenue
il y a beaucoup de thèmes à aborder dans
dans ce débat la loi martiale je le
disais en titre décrété par Vladimir
Poutine la bataille de Carson qui se
prépare mais aussi on en parlera les
tensions franco-allemandes qui peinent à
trouver une réponse commune face à la
flambée des prix de l'énergie comme
toujours cette ce conflit en Ukraine a
beaucoup de tiroirs et beaucoup de
problématiques à aborder je commence par
les sanctions europ week-end et cette
histoire de drone iranien Gallia
Ackerman est-ce qu'elles peuvent freiner
l'Iran on a vu on a vu des réactions un
peu embarrassées ceux qui fournissent
ces drames ces drones à la Russie je
crois que ça ne va pas freiner les rangs
l'Iran est un habitué des sanctions
occidentales il est subi depuis de très
nombreuses années et on ne sait pas ça
c'est le bâton mais on ne sait pas
quelle est la carotte et la carotte dans
les relations et iraniennes est
importante parce que les rues sont
construits ont TD à construire à l'Iran
la centrale de bouchère il y a d'autres
projets à l'étude et puis entre les pays
parisiens on se sert un peu les coudes
donc probablement
tout en ayant son implication
l'Iran quel que soit le coût des
sanctions pour lui va continuer à en
fournir à l'Ukraine pardon à la Russie
et ce qui veut dire en clair que
l'instauration de système de défense et
d'autant plus urgent parce que c'est
drone sont utilisés essentiellement pour
détruire les infrastructures électriques
on y reviendra aux infrastructures
électriques c'est essentiel avec l'hiver
qui approche Irina de mitrychin et
effectivement il y a cette demande de du
président zellinski pour avoir une pour
renforcer on va dire sa défense
antimissiles et anthydrone sont pas
forcément les mêmes armes vous nous le
confirmerez peut-être un mot de la
population de ce que vit la population
c'est quoi c'est la nouvelle terreur des
Ukrainiens c'est drone iranien est-ce
qu'on peut dire ça on est conscient que
ces drones peuvent frapper n'importe où
et que surtout il frappe les
infrastructures civiles électriques ce
qui prive les villes entières de
d'électricité donc de chauffage donc
et donc l'ensemble ce service très
rapidement transforme les villes enfin
les plonge au Moyen-Âge parce que il y a
ces services vitaux qui disparaissent
donc les gens aujourd'hui s'équipent en
système de chauffage
donc qui serait
autonome
achète les ballons d'eau enfin les fonds
des stocks pour parer à ces à ses
coupures qui sont déjà pratiquement
instaurer donc ce qu'on appelle les les
coupures sélectives dans dans la journée
on a demandé aux habitants de la
capitale notamment à réduire leur
consommation ou changer leur habitude de
consommation électrique à passer les
choses dans la nuit je peux faire la
lessive la nuit plutôt que dans la
journée donc il y a déjà une
anticipation de la part de la population
civile de la part des autorités qui non
seulement prévoient les choses et
ensuite essayer de pallier très
rapidement lorsque une centrale ou un
système et hors d'usage général gaumar
c'est drone iranien c'est quoi c'est
c'est rustique c'est robuste c'est de la
haute technologie c'est très précis
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire ce sont des
petits drones en fait qui sont pas très
très grands je crois qu'ils ont 30 à 40
cm d'envergure contrairement au drone
turc dont on parlait beaucoup au début
de la guerre qui sont des des mini
avions en fait l'un coûte en 20000
dollars le drone iranien et l'autre
coûtant 2 millions de dollars donc en
fait il y a une petite différence c'est
pas du tout la même technologie en fait
c'est ce sont des drones type les drones
Parrot c'est-à-dire un peu plus gros
qu'un drone Parrot avec une charge
suffisamment importante pour détruire
effectivement une centrale électrique
pour détruire en fait les
infrastructures énergétiques
ukrainienne l'idée étant effectivement
que avant l'hiver les Ukrainiens lèvent
les pouces en disant stop en fait c'est
vraiment un impact pour avoir un impact
psychologique c'est pas pour autant dire
que les Ukrainiens diront stop bien au
contraire on sent bien une population
ukrainienne avec une force morale très
puissante quelles seront les
conséquences exactes maintenant lutter
contre ce type de drone est assez et pas
si simple que ça et qu'on parlait de
défense anti-aérienne parce qu'autant en
défense aérienne antimissile j'allais
dire on a des systèmes et la France a un
système donne un système Cobra l'Ukraine
pour nous-mêmes on a construit l'Italie
un système qui s'appelle Mamba qui sont
des systèmes type le patriotes
américains ou le S300 russe c'est le
système anti-missiles pour les drones
c'est un peu différent et on voit bien
les difficultés même pour nos policiers
nos gendarmes en France de lutter contre
des drones qui pourraient effectivement
attaquer vibraine des images des
endroits dont on ne souhaite pas où on
ne souhaite pas que les gens pas des
images etc etc donc oui la lutte
antidrone est une vraie un vrai une
vraie gageur pour demain pour toutes les
armées du monde mais pour tous les pays
et surtout et alors on a dit sur ce
plateau il y a quelques jours lors des
des premières frappes russes cette série
de Sales on avait vu qu'il y avait des
missiles des années 60 qui avait été
utilisés dans certains cas est-ce que
c'est drone iranien ils viennent alors
vous nous avez un peu répondu en disant
que c'était pas du tout la même chose
mais est-ce qu'il y a une supplie le
manque de munition et le manque de
missiles de l'armée russe est-ce qu'on
peut dire ça en fait la technique russe
s'est tapé dans la profondeur avant
d'utiliser les soldats on voit bien
d'ailleurs la problématique des Russes
et qui ont mobilisé de manière partielle
c'est leur nombre de soldats
c'est-à-dire la masse humaine pour
combler ça en réalité ils utilisent
beaucoup leur artillerie les munitions
aujourd'hui ils ont dû en utiliser
énormément donc est-ce qu'ils en a
encore beaucoup ça je le sais pas mais
en fait ils avaient quand même des
stocks très très importants même chose
que des Ukrainiens et effectivement ça
permet d'atteindre des objectifs que
nous pouvons pas atteindre avec
l'artillerie et ça permet de cibler
beaucoup plus précisément puisque ces
drones vont être guidés directement sur
l'objectif alors que les obus autant les
obus d'un canon César sont guidés
pratiquement jusqu'à la phase terminale
ce n'est pas le cas des obus russes en
revanche un drone vous pouvez le guider
sur l'objectif que vous visez donc en
fait c'est beaucoup plus précis une
réaction celle du président ukrainien
volet diverselenski justement sur cette
stratégie de viser les installations
électriques écoutées
il y a de nouveaux dommages aux
infrastructures critiques aujourd'hui
trois installations énergétiques ont été
détruites par l'ennemi bien sûr nous
ferons tout notre possible pour rétablir
les capacités énergétiques normales de
notre pays mais ça prend du temps et ça
nécessite nos efforts conjoints
d'infrastructures justement électriques
de centrale ont déjà été touchés
détruites partiellement ou totalement
on parlait de 30% aujourd'hui on parle
de 40% ce qui est tout à fait énorme je
vous rappelle qu'il y a quelques temps
encore le président Zelinski a même
proposé à l'Europe son électricité parce
qu'ils en avaient assez il y a plusieurs
centrales nucléaires il y a des
centrales hydroélectriques il y a des
centrales au charbon etc et donc
le crâne a été très bien fourni en
électricité mais 40%
c'est énorme mais on ne sait pas quand
est-ce que ça va s'arrêter parce que
quand on écoute les médias russe en fait
les propagandistes du régime appellent à
la destruction complète de des
infrastructures critiques et en premier
lieu l'électricité qui est pratiquement
la base de tout les questions peut-être
un peu naïve l'Ukraine ne peut pas
rétorquer de la même façon
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué pour
l'Ukraine c'est que depuis le début en
fait ils ont pas tellement tapé le sol
russe finalement à part du côté de
Belgorod où ils ont détruit je crois des
des dépôts de carburant ou des dépôts de
munitions mais c'est la seule chose
qu'ils aient faites mais c'est vrai que
on peut se poser la question
peuvent aussi taper je pense qu'ils ont
donné moyen souvenons-nous que les
Américains n'ont pas voulu donner de
l'armement qui permettait de taper sur
le sol russe c'est les mars ils en ont
limité la portée a été alors c'est ça
pose la question de l'escalade etc en
fait c'est mais vous avez raison c'est
une bonne question
qu'est-ce qu'on sait de la réaction des
des Ukrainiens parce que il y a quand
même peut-être une crainte de d'exode
face à ce risque notamment de dans les
villes qui sont principalement touchées
je parlais m'ont répété cette scansion
de Zelinski ça sert à sans électricité
sans eau mais ça les Russes donc
tout à fait donc les gens ne absolument
pas à ce stade prête à renoncer un
négocier à quoi que ce soit donc il sert
les dents et s'apprête à résister mais
Gallia justement que l'émission démarre
vous disiez il y a quand même une
possibilité que finalement on insiste à
un mouvement vers les campagnes pourquoi
oui certainement et je connais aussi des
exemples très concrets parmi les gens
que je connais en Ukraine parce que
quand vous vivez dans une maison
individuelle vous vous chauffez avec une
poêle et cette poêle elle fonctionne au
bois or il n'y a pas de défaut de bois
manque de bois en Ukraine et pareil vous
avez une cave donc vous pouvez stocker
la nourriture même si le frigo ne marche
pas
vous avez des puits donc l'eau est
accessible et finalement
s'il n'y a pas d'électricité il y a des
bougies donc c'est c'est beaucoup plus
supportable que quand vous êtes coincé
dans un appartement en ville que
excusez-moi la chasse d'eau ne
fonctionne plus qui a plutôt et donc il
faut descendre plusieurs étages vous
savez je rappelle que par exemple la
Kiev il y a beaucoup d'immeubles devant
étage plus qu'est-ce que vont faire les
gens qui sont là donc je pense qu'il y
aura un certain exode vers la campagne
pour passer l'hiver tout simplement
parce que pour beaucoup de gens c'est
pas possible autrement et probablement
il y aura un exode supplémentaire aussi
vers l'Europe on finit par s'habituer
mais Irina nutrition il y a encore
beaucoup du créé on l'imagine avec les
bombardements qui qui vivent une partie
de la journée parfois toute la journée
sous terre dans le métro s'il y a
toujours cette vie souterraine dans dans
les villes dans les grandes villes
ukrainiennes tout à fait on en parle
presque plus mais c'est ça le quotidien
des Ukrainiens aujourd'hui absolument
avec ces bombardements qui ont repris
n'oublions pas qu'il y a beaucoup de
enfin plusieurs millions du camp qui
sont rentrés depuis le premier départ et
les gens sont confrontés à à ce nouveau
bombardement donc les villes comme rares
qui comme micro euh sont bombardés
constamment maintenant c'est c'est le
tour de la capitale mais il y a d'autres
villes plus à l'ouest qui ont été dont
les infrastructures ont été touchées
donc les gens vivent constamment avec
les alertes
anti-aériennes et si vous avez une
application sur votre téléphone qui
fonctionne même en France vous pouvez
tout à fait vivre en temps réel c'est
enfin ces heures et qu'il faut passer
dans les dans les cas avant de pouvoir
ressortir reprendre une vie normale on
va parler maintenant de la loi martiale
avec Jérémie heinzman vous pouvez nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau Jérémy bonsoir
bienvenue pour revenir sur cette
décision annoncée ce mercredi par
Vladimir Poutine l'instauration de la
loi martiale dans les quatre territoires
Ukrainiens illégalement annexé oui
c'était lors d'une réunion d'un Conseil
de sécurité diffusé à la télévision et
on va réécouter justement l'annonce du
président russe
le régime de Kiev refuse de reconnaître
la volonté du peuple rejette toute
proposition de négociation les tirs
continuent des civils meurent
c'est pourquoi j'ai signé un décret sur
l'introduction de la loi martiale dans
ces quatre sujets de la Fédération de
Russie à partir de ce jeudi minuit la
loi martiale entreera donc en vigueur
dans les territoires de Donetsk Logan
Kerson et zapporijah passé sous
l'autorité de la Russie en septembre et
déjà placé sous haute surveillance pas
de grands changements donc mais
concrètement cela signifie que l'armée
russe dispose désormais des plans
pouvoirs juridiques et de police dans
ces régions et selon la loi une série de
mesures de restriction des libertés
pourraient être mis en place
renforcement des mesures de sécurité
couvre-feu interdiction des
rassemblements publics évacuation
d'entreprises stratégiques interdiction
de quitter les territoires concernés
internement de population ou encore
censure militaire dans les
télécommunications
la conscription pourrait aussi devenir
obligatoire permettant à la Russie
d'enrôler des citoyens qui étaient
Ukrainiens il y a encore quelques
semaines et cette loi martiale n'est pas
la seule mesure décrétée par Vladimir
Poutine et non le chef du Kremlin a
également relevé le niveau d'alerte dans
toutes les régions du territoire russe
limitrophes de l'Ukraine et dans la
Crimée annexée elle en 2014 dans ces
zones les gouverneurs auront des
pouvoirs élargi pour prendre des mesures
sécuritaires une manière pour Vladimir
Poutine de reprendre la main face à Kiev
après les revers de Carson mais pour le
président américain Joe Biden il s'agit
plutôt d'un aveu de faiblesse écoutez-le
je pense que Vladimir Poutine se trouve
dans une situation incroyablement
difficile
mais il semblerait que le seul outil qui
reste à sa disposition soit de
persécuter les citoyens ukrainiens afin
de les intimider pour les amener à une
capitulation mais ce n'est pas ce qu'ils
vont faire
de son côté le Kremlin a précisé qu'il
n'était pas question de fermer les
frontières de la Russie une décision qui
a été redoutée par une partie de la
population merci beaucoup Jérémy pour
toutes ces informations
erinier je reviens vers vous cette loi
martiale si on se si on se concentre un
peu et on va en parler tous ensemble sur
la situation dans la ville de Carson
qu'est-ce que ça permet de faire on
parle beaucoup de l'évacuation de la
population en ce moment qu'est-ce qui
est en train de se passer une partie de
la population qui est poussée ou
convaincu d'une manière d'une autre à
partir il y a quand même beaucoup de
gens qui restent et ces gens
implicitement seront considérés comme
les soutiens de l'Ukraine en tout cas
ceux qui restent pour attendre le retour
de l'Ukraine et je crains surtout pour
cette population là qui reste qui va
être soumise à des restrictions à des
contrôles à à des privations mais aussi
à des réquisitions parce que ça veut
dire que toutes les véhicules personnel
ou les biens d'une entreprise peuvent à
tout moment être questionnés et
contribue à l'effort de guerre et puis
pour ceux qui sont amenés de gré ou de
force on ne sait pas où ils vont se
retrouver est-ce qu'ils ont la
possibilité de de revenir et quel serait
quel serait leur sort en Russie parce
que les promesses qui sont faites de
leur donner un logement le couverture
sociale etc on y croit bien général
gomard pourquoi les Russes sont-ils en
train d'évacuer Carson qu'est-ce qui est
en train de se préparer là parce que
quand on les Russes qui étaient à
l’offensive sont passés en défensive et
quand on est en défensive utiliser un
point clé du terrain c'est-à-dire une
ville permet de mieux se défendre vous
savez que on en termes de chiffres on
dit que pour prendre une ville il faut
être cuite assaillant contre un
défenseur parce que combattre en ville
est extrêmement compliqué ça peut être
piégé on peut y laisser des tas de
choses trap il suffit d'un tireur pour
bloquer une rue etc donc en fait ils
vont se sans doute pour moi se servait
de la ville pour freiner l'avancée
ukrainienne et la vie sera sans doute en
partie détruite puisque quand on se sert
d'une ville pour se battre effectivement
le risque est qu'à salon de maison
d'immeubles soit détruit donc il pousse
en effet la population évacuée
effectivement comme ils airena ce qui
reste reconsidéré comme attendant les
Ukrainiens pourquoi les Ukrainiens vous
ne voulez pas vous interrompez vous
l'avez dit il y a une partie de la
population de Carson qui est évacué sans
doute de force enfin bref on va on va
l'évoquer un peu vers la Russie avec des
promesses et sans qu'on sache exactement
ce qui va se passer donc les autres
seront considérés comme des
pro-ukrainiens comme un doux attendant
leur armée quoi c'est tout la loi
martiale d'ailleurs qui va empêcher ses
citoyens qui sont restés de sortir ils
vont être surveillés d'autant plus près
et dès qu'ils feront un mouvement de
travers ils sont sans doute mis en
prison ou que sais-je
et ils vont être considérés pourquoi
cette loi martiale c'est pour éviter que
ces gens-là deviennent des futurs
résistants ou j'allais dire créer
attaque l'armée russe par le comme le
font des résistances je pense que c'est
ça qui est derrière
sont forcés on a du mal à comprendre la
série gauche pour l'instant c'est gauche
de conséquences
de qui reste et de qui part les Russes
moi je pense que c'est un peu la même
logique que les évacuations pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale parce que quand
vous savez les villes à l'approche de
l'armée allemande plusieurs grandes
villes y compris d'ailleurs ont été
évacués mais il ne s'agissait jamais de
l'évacuation de toute la population en
premier lieu on évacué qui les
collaborateurs enfin les membres du
parti qui est occupé des postes
quelconques les dirigeants ce qu'on
appelle
soviétique c'est à dire des dirigeants
de différentes institutions on évacué
des usines ensemble avec leurs ouvriers
on avait cuit pas tout le monde jamais
donc là je pense que il y a deux groupes
de population probablement qu'on évacue
en premier lieu les collabos excusez-moi
l'expression c'est-à-dire
son a été quand même
occupée sans bataille pratiquement il y
a eu de la contestation au sein de la
ville après son occupation mais
apparemment il y a eu aussi des
complaisances et des collaborations il y
a ça veut dire pardon on reprendra votre
démonstration sur les deux populations
mais là si on se concentre sur ce que
vous appelez les collabos je voudrais
juste bien comprendre la ville est
tombée sans sans combat donc il y a eu
quoi il y a une sorte de trahison il y a
eu trop russe qui laissait la ville
c'est ce que vous faites il y a eu une
sorte de trahison et les champs qui ont
des miner à l'approche de personnes ont
été déminées sur les ordres d'un traître
ukrainien si je comprends bien et donc
et donc l'armée a pris personne ensuite
il y a eu une sorte de résistance il y a
eu plusieurs fois des meetings etc tous
ces gens peu à peu ont été arrêtés où
ils ont fui où ils ont disparu
maintenant
il y a eu une administration ça
s'appelle
militarro civil qui a été instauré par
les Russes les écoles ont ouvert avec
les programmes russes et donc il y a eu
quand même une collaboration de la part
de milliers et milliers de personnes
cette partie là on les évacue parce que
pour service rendu en quelque sorte bien
sûr et puis il y a ceux qu'on va
déporter pardon de le terme beaucoup de
connotations donc hésite à l'employer
mais c'est un peu ça les Russes
affirment qu'il n'y a pas de déportation
mais en fait la technique est la même
partout dans le territoire occupés quand
les Russes s'emparent d'une huile il
faut signer aux habitants un papier
comme quoi il
consente
à une évacuation si besoin en fait les
gens sont obligés de le signer parce que
sans ce papier ils peuvent pas avoir par
exemple les rations alimentaires l'aide
de manière tout ça donc ils peuvent
toujours actionner ça en disant voilà
maintenant on vous a signé maintenant
vous partez l'idée étant je pense que
c'est pas parce que ils veulent
préserver ces gens mais vous savez en
Russie il y a quand même une situation
démographique très tendue et depuis le
début de ce conflit les Russes
font tout leur possible pour évacuer les
populations même là où
il n'était pas menacé comme maintenant à
personne y compris des centaines de
milliers d'enfants qui ensuite sont
donnés à des familles d'accueil
lucifiées etc
de repeuplement de certaines zones où la
démographie est en berne depuis
plusieurs années
c'est une des définitions de génocide
parce que on prive le crâne de ses
habitants on vide le crâne de ses
habitants Irina nutrition que sait-on de
parce que là on parle de Carson mais
c'est déjà arrivé à Karman vient nous le
rappeler dans d'autres villes d'Ukraine
que sait-on de ces Ukrainiens qui ont
été déportés je reprends le mot vers la
Russie c'est très difficile de le suivre
et bien sûr les situations les plus
dramatiques c'est les enfants c'est les
mineurs qui sont
soi-disant évacués ensuite en perle la
trace ensuite on sait qu'il y a eu des
facilitations d'adoption qui avait été
consenties par la Russie et on a peur de
ne jamais retrouver ses enfants en même
temps on entend de temps en temps le
retour de d'un groupe d'enfants ou d'un
orphelinat etc donc il y a comme les
structures qui essaient de suivre ce qui
se passe et surtout de de vrai pour le
retour de de ses enfants il y a aussi
des des réseaux qui s'organisent aussi
bien en Russie que dans par exemple les
pays baltes ou les gens essaient de
d'aller vers la frontière et ensuite de
de pouvoir passer je pense que les plus
toniques vont essayer de de passer et
réussissent il y aura malheureusement
des gens qui vont qui vont être mises
dans les situations privées de leur
papier
envoyer très très loin qui auront
beaucoup de mal à revenir et ensuite on
verra il y a sans doute aussi un
pourcentage de la population qui qui
préfère aller en Russie donc les
situations sont extrêmement diverses oui
alors ça aussi je vais revenir à la
stratégie militaire dans un instant mais
gagner un mot là-dessus dans vous l'avez
un peu évoqué en disant Kerson a eu des
des trahisons ou en tout cas donc il y a
une partie de la population de la ville
si on veut être très lucide qui est
prorus quand même certainement oh ok on
t'a accepté en tout cas de collaborer
vous savez on sait pas qu'est-ce qui est
dans la tête par exemple des enseignants
ils ont ouvert les écoles mais avec un
autre programme ils ont amené les
manuels qui ont été imprimés en Russie
et ils ont imposé des programmes russes
maintenant il y a probablement
peut-être des des instituteurs
institutrices qui l'ont accepté
volontiers il y en a d'autres qui
peut-être ont été forcés de le faire
parce que au moins ils avaient un
salaire et il pouvait continuer à
travailler donc est-ce qu'ils sont tous
des traîtres non mais ce sont des gens
qui d'une façon ou d'une autre ont
collaboré la question s'était posée en
Crimée aussi d'ailleurs
depuis 2014 et l'Ukraine a beaucoup
réfléchi sur ces sujets et le mot
d'ordre aujourd'hui qui est transmis
c'est de dire que on ne considère comme
collabo que ceux qui ont ouvertement
soutenu ou
œuvré par exemple pour l'organisation
des soignants référendum donc qui ont en
tout cas qui ont salué et qui ont
soutenu
ces autorités mais récemment personne
fallait l'ensemble de du de l'Ukraine a
été ému par le cas d'un chef d'orchestre
qui a refusé de collaborer et qui a été
figé dans dans sa maison donc et akirson
la ville effectivement a été prise très
rapidement mais on se souvient de ces
manifestations de ces gens qui se
jetaient sur les sur les chats qui
sortaient avec les drapeaux Ukrainiens
on sait ensuite qu'il y a eu des camps
de filtrations qui ont des arrestations
de disparition donc donc plusieurs mois
d'occupation ça brise quand même les
crèmes tous ceux qui est tous ceux qui
pouvaient résister et ça réduit au
silence ceux qui essaient de survivre
Christophe womard je reviens donc à la
stratégie militaire de de Moscou
notamment dans cette région mais pas
seulement est-ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est une nouvelle phase de la de la
guerre qui qui a commencé depuis
quelques jours qui va commencer oui
enfin bon il y a la première phase qui
était un véritable échec c'était la
tentative de prise par surprise de Kiev
et de renversement du président ski une
deuxième face et l'utilisation massive
de son artillerie même chose échec enfin
une espèce de ligne de front et une
tendance à reculer et une troisième
phase dans laquelle il à la fois il
mobilise partiellement pour essayer de
renverser le rapport de force grâce à la
masse numérique humaine et tout en
détruisant par ailleurs les
infrastructures énergétiques du pays
pour essayer de faire capituler la
population mais que m'a très bien
souligné le président zélinski comme
Erina en fait il y a une force dame dans
cette population ukrainienne Poutine la
victoire de Poutine c'est la création
d'une véritable nation ukrainienne en
réalité
et on voit bien que c'était ça sa
stratégie militaire et derrière il
espère faire plier cette population qui
ne plie pas et une armée ukrainienne qui
s'est renforcée en même temps alors que
l'armée russe au contraire j'allais dire
c'est à Moinerie et le rapport de force
qu'on pensait au départ favorable russe
et en fait favorable à l'armée
ukrainienne d'aujourd'hui renforcer non
seulement par cette force d’âme et cette
volonté d'un pays qui sait pourquoi il
veut gagner et qui voit un but et un
objectif contrairement à l'armée russe
en réalité et plus l'armement occidental
et le renseignement occidental alors
justement vous étiez chef du
Renseignement donc là les Américains
jouent un rôle très important les
Américains mais les Occidentaux aussi et
la France la France également parce que
la France communique assez peu
finalement c'est
toujours été la position de la France je
sais par ailleurs qu'en fait ils
fournissent du renseignement ils ont
fourni des 25% de l'artillerie française
ils fournissent des cobraïs ils
fournissent un tas de choses donc après
il y a du France bashing c'est certain
mais nous n'aurons pas la France aide
l'Ukraine soutient l'Ukraine donc du
renseignement c'est quoi c'est de des
satellites
c'est l'imagerie satellitaires c'est de
l'interception ça peut du renseignement
cybernétique ça peut être du
renseignement parce que il y a des il y
a des sources également voilà donc en
fait oui oui il y a un fourniture de
renseignement
qu'est-ce qu'on sait de de
déserteurs dans l'armée russe puisque là
on est on est finalement sur les forces
et faiblesses des uns et des autres il y
a il y a des messages qui sont envoyés
par l'armée ukrainienne vers les Russes
un est-ce que on a des chiffres je pense
que c'est très compliqué puis deux
est-ce que c'est médiatisé quand des
soldats russes se rendent
on a d'abord lancé cette plateforme je
veux vivre donc on a diffusé ces numéros
de téléphone qui qui ont que la Russie a
essayé de bloquer on sait qu'il y a eu
quand même des appels on sait qu'il y a
eu des passages des desersions on sait
surtout qu'il y a cette délices de de
l'armée et c'est ces officiers au
soldats qui refusent de de combattre
donc on compte aussi un petit peu là
dessus sur sur cette effondrement de
l'armée russe surtout face à
l'extraordinaire organisation et la
montée en puissance de de l'armement
ukrainien alors là je reviens vers vous
parce que justement cette armée russe
qu'on présentait comme l'une des plus
puissantes au monde elle sait pas non
plus dégonflée en quelques mois que il
faut pas être trop optimiste entre
guillemets sur la capacité à faire plier
l'armée russe qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez je pense qu'il faut pas vendre la
peau de l'ours russe avant d'avoir tué
ça c'est certain et que l'armée russe
existe toujours et elle existera encore
je pense un bon moment
mon point de vue c'est qu'ils ont
beaucoup investi dans l'espace ils ont
beaucoup investi dans les technologies
modernes comme les missiles hypersonique
ou les ou les torpilles hyper vélos dans
leur armée dans l'armée de l'air peu
dans l'armée de terre finalement
contrairement aux Ukrainiens qui ont
beaucoup plus investi dans leur armée de
terre en fait or une armée de terre ça
fait pour tenir le terrain si vous
faites la guerre avec des bombardiers
avec des missiles et vous tenez pas le
terrain ça marche ça ne peut pas
fonctionner et en fait l'armée russe est
beaucoup de char elle a réutilisé comme
l'armée ukrainienne beaucoup de chars de
matériel soviétiques ancien modèle on a
vu des 62 descendus c'est-à-dire que les
chars construit en 62 donc oui c'est des
tas des T72 construit en 1972 et donc
l'armée de terre ukrainienne est
beaucoup plus forte en fait que l'armée
de terre russe ils n'ont pas
suffisamment de fantassins une armée a
besoin de chars de canon et de
fantassins pour tenir le terrain et je
pense que l'erreur russe a été celle là
et aujourd'hui on voit bien que le
rapport de force a changé et que l'armée
ukrainienne d'ailleurs est à l'offensive
et qu'elle progresse doucement sûrement
et on voit bien Carson l'évacue son
Carson c'est bien la preuve que les
Ukrainiens avancent Gaïa Kerman il y a
eu la cette mobilisation partielle quand
même de de
oui de futurs soldats enfin on en est où
de leur déploiement sur le terrain qu'il
fallait les former on les a on a pris le
temps de les former un petit peu pas du
tout on en est où certains ont été
envoyés directement en front et ils ont
eu déjà le temps d'être tué juste après
quelques jours de cette mobilisation
d'autres sont formés dans des bases il y
a des reportages bien sûr comme toujours
très optimistes mais on sait très bien
je pense que le général Gomar
confirmera ceci pour former aujourd'hui
un soldat moderne il faut à peu près 6
mois c'est six mois ils n'auront pas
s'ils ont deux semaines c'est déjà
beaucoup ensuite on sait pas comment ils
sont équipés il paraît que en tout cas
dans les premières semaines de cette
mobilisation ont demandé agenda
d'arriver avec leur uniforme avec leur
kit de premiers secours et avec leurs
conserve de l'acheter eux-mêmes quoi
on ne sait pas comment ils sont préparés
à l'hiver probablement mal parce que le
gros problème de l'armée russe c'est la
corruption la corruption qui
gangrène tout le pays ne peut pas
épargner l'armée on sait qu'encore dans
les premières années pour soviétiques
les officiers sur Youtube simplement
vendez vendaient les chars vendaient les
armements par exemple au yougoslave
mais d'autres pays aussi voilà parce que
parce que il fallait bien vivre et donc
tout était bon à vendre et aujourd'hui
c'est d'ailleurs l'un des propagandise
du régime qui a clamé
donc à la télévision en disant ceci il
est il était mais vraiment dans un état
extrêmement énervé et il disait vous
savez sur papier notre armée à 2
millions de personnes donc un million
150 000 de soldats de militaires
je comprends de cela que c'est 850
personnes qui s'occupent de
l'approvisionnement et enfin de tous les
services
commençons déjà que c'est pas du tout un
ratio normal en ratio normal c'est pour
un militaire qui se bat pour un
combattant il faut cinq ou six personnes
qui qui
le dessert dessert qui le soutiennent
voilà mais et donc mais lui sur le haut
il hurlait mais où sont-ils c'est un
million 150000 maintenant nous avons
encore mobilisé 300 000 donc ça fait en
450 000 et où sont-ils on les voit pas
et donc ça nous pose un vrai une vraie
question où sont-ils parce que bien sûr
bon il y a il y a des soldats qui
gardent des frontières il y a des bases
militaires etc mais probablement s'il y
avait
si tous ces soldats existaient peut-être
on aurait pu les voir aussi en Ukraine
si on ne les voit pas est-ce que ça ne
signifie pas qu'une partie ce sont des
amortes pour lesquelles on reçoit des
des soldes
des rations etc etc on ne mesure pas la
profondeur de la déliquescence de
l'armée russe et pourquoi parce que
jusque là et depuis l'éclatement de
l'Union soviétique donc pendant plus de
30 ans il y avait pratiquement pas
d'opération sur terre sauf une petite
cette guerre en Géorgie et la Géorgie
c'est un petit pays de 3 millions
d'habitants donc c'est clair que les
Russes étaient quand même
qu'ils ont pu gagner en quelques jours
occupés du territoire etc mais en Syrie
par exemple les Russes ne sont pas
battus au sol et ils ont bombardé
seulement c'était les Syriens et les
Iraniens qui sont battus au sol et donc
et donc voilà
la question la grande question où
sont-ils où sont-ils ils ouvrent un
dernier pardon nous avons interrompu
mais je voudrais prendre un peu de temps
pour un dernier chapitre dans ce débat
les les conseils c'est important les
conséquences économiques de la guerre
notamment au sein de l'Union européenne
les dirigeants de l'Union qui se
réunissent ce jeudi et vendredi à
Bruxelles pour tenter de surmonter leur
division et de trouver une une réponse
commune à la flambée de l'énergie la
France et l'Allemagne pour l'instant ne
sont pas d'accord on écoute le
chancelier allemand il refuse un prix
plafonné
un prix plafonné par l'UE comporte
toutefois toujours le risque que les
producteurs vendent ensuite leur gaz
ailleurs et que nous les Européens nous
retrouvions avec moins de gaz au lieu de
plus c'est pourquoi l'UE doit se
coordonner étroitement avec d'autres
consommateurs de gaz comme par exemple
le Japon et la Corée afin de ne pas se
concurrenter les uns les autres Laetitia
en est au cœur des préoccupations des
opinions publiques européennes les prix
de l'énergie et c'est pour ça que la
guerre en Ukraine ça fait finalement
encore partie des préoccupations des
Français oui et finalement on voit qu'il
y a des dissensions entre Emmanuel
Macron et Olaf schollz mais il y a une
enquête de l'Ifop qui montre que deux
tiers des Allemands et des Français sont
d'accord sur les sanctions économiques
et que 60% approuvent aussi les
livraisons d'armes par l'Europe donc
vous voyez qu'il y a quand même une
dissension aussi entre les opinions
publiques et leurs dirigeants et bien
sûr que les français et sont concernés
ça fait partie des préoccupations
vraiment des Français princip normal
quand on leur pose la question dans
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion en cette
rentrée et c'est d'ailleurs peut-être la
raison pour laquelle Emmanuel Macron a
donné cette interview télévisée ou
l'Ukraine prenait une grande place la
semaine dernière il fallait rassurer et
d'ailleurs le matin même vaut le
démerdeinski et son équipe bien sûr de
communication avait envoyé sur les
réseaux vous l'avez sans doute vu une
vidéo pour démontrer cet amour
franco-ukrainien relativement neuf à
grand renfort de symboles des cœurs du
chocolat peut-être aussi des roses et
puis des canons
[Musique]
je faisais je veux rien
du Serge Gainsbourg pour vanter l'amitié
franco-ukrainienne et les Césars c'est
ça sur les canaux dont on dont on parle
est-ce que ça a eu un impact direct sur
le moral des Français pas sûr non ça n'a
pas eu d'impact visiblement d'autant
qu'on a appris que la France était l'un
des trois pays à aller former maintenant
sur son sol les futurs militaires ou les
militaires
Ukrainiens donc il y a quand même une
sorte de d'inquiétude chez les Français
qui se mesure encore une fois la semaine
dernière l'Ifop a fait paraître une
enquête où les résultats sont
implacables regardez l'infographie qui
va apparaître sur l'écran et 87 % des
Français sont inquiets des conséquences
économiques de cette guerre 80% sont
inquiets de l'utilisation des armes
nucléaires
71% craignent la survenue d'une
troisième guerre mondiale et même 62%
ont carrément peur d'une attaque
nucléaire sur le sol français donc on
comprend non avec ces données à la fois
le climat d'inquiétude qui règne en
cette rentrée alors que les Français
sont confrontés aussi à des questions
intérieures les conflits sociaux les
pénuries de carburants la crise
énergétique mais quand même cette grande
inquiétude demeure concernant la guerre
en Ukraine avec assez peu de disparité
en fonction des catégories sociales oui
alors ça c'est très clair par exemple
sur les conséquences économiques
l'inquiétude est exactement la même
quelle que soit le statut socio
professionnel c'est-à-dire qu'un ouvrier
ou un cadre supérieur est également
inquiet comme un dirigeant d'entreprise
ou un salarié la seule petite nuance
dans cette enquête de l'ifope c'est sur
la question de l'attaque nucléaire sur
le sol français où il y a il y a une
disparité en fonction du niveau du
diplôme 41% des détenteurs de diplôme
supérieur n'y pensent pas vraiment
contre 69% pour les 100 diplômes alors
est-ce que les diplômés sont plus
optimistes ou mieux informés seul
l'avenir nous le dira on a consacré
toute une partie de notre émission hier
à cette à cette menace nucléaire donc je
vais pas revenir de dessus mais je
voudrais Irina mitrychin peut-être faire
un gros plan sur la communication du
Président zenki parce que là on a vu ce
clip destiné aux Français il y a
toujours ce travail vis-à-vis enfin il y
a eu des clips pour d'autres pays vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
il saisit l'occasion de parler au bon
moment à une opinion publique oui il a
une équipe de communicants et ils n'ont
pas découvert la force de la
communication aujourd'hui ils sont forts
c'est parce que ils travaillent depuis
longtemps ça ça élection a été gagnée
comme ça donc n'oublions pas que ce sont
des professionnels de de communication
et je dois dire qu'il tape souvent juste
qu'il ne sont jamais au là où on les
attend et c'est plutôt efficace et ça
montre aussi qu'est-ce qu'il est entouré
des trentenaires parfaitement maîtrisant
les les réseaux et on le voit aussi à
l'intérieur il n'y a pas que la
communication à l'extérieur on voit
comment à l'intérieur un ministère de
finance peut quitter quelque chose et
ministère de la répondent donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui un jour ça
étudié dans les dans les écoles de
communication avec sur le moral de la
population ukrainienne c'est évidemment
très important quoi les les mots la
force des mots des dirigeants c'est ça
peut être galvanisant absolument
j'ai souvent cité ici évidemment les le
le souvenir de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et du rôle de Churchill
notamment dans l'année 1941 quand
finalement le parallèle il est assez
évident quand les grandes villes
britanniques subissaient le bombardement
le le Blist le bombardement allemand
j'aurais terminé général Gomar avec vous
sur le peut-être l'enjeu de c'est de ces
prochains jours là parce qu'on dit
souvent l'hiver va arriver donc ça va
peut-être pas d'ailleurs figé les
positions c'est quoi l'enjeu des
prochains jours alors je pour les les
Ukrainiens c'est de continuer à avancer
de franchir le nia prend en réalité pour
les Russes c'est de stabiliser une ligne
de front en attendant les soldats
mobilisés la formation le soldat
mobilisé parce que Gallia Kamal le
disait un soldat c'est deux mois de
classe normalement et si on veut le
former un peu plus dans sa spécialité
c'est 2 à 4 mois supplémentaires donc il
faut un peu de temps et envoyer un
soldat sans formation initiale même s'il
s'est chasser il sait pas se déplacer
sur le terrain il ne sait pas s'abriter
il ne sait pas s'orienter il sait pas
forcément vraiment bien utilisé son arme
etc parce qu'un soldat ne travaille
jamais seul il est toujours entouré donc
en fait cette c'est un collectif qui
fait que l'on gagne une guerre donc pour
moi la guerre va durer malheureusement
mais je pense plutôt une stabilisation
d'une ligne de front avec c'est ce qu'il
faut voir c'est combien de temps on va
durer les bombardements russes sur
l'Ukraine pour la destruction en
particulier des sites énergétiques des
centrales électriques et des centrales
thermiques etc c'est ça c'est un vrai
sujet
auquel on doit réfléchir pour pouvoir
mieux protéger les les Ukrainiens en
effet merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat Gallia
Carmen je rappelle le voilà ce numéro
spécial de la règle du jeu 500 pages
consacré à l'Ukraine et finalement
vraiment à la Russie aussi évidemment
merci encore à tous les trois dernières
participer à ce à ce premier débat